e
on four house
bills we may as well take them in the
order they're that they're shown on
the on the agenda first one is House
Bill 1212
which on the house Flor FL it originally
went to the house floor as
itl that got uh flipped and ended up as
an
OTP that's why we have it
ballpark so is anybody have any comments
on this on the the the bill itself yes
Mr chair we have um one of the uh Co
sponsor primary sponsor uh could we
please thank you representative Muriel
Hall represent Bo in hopkington and all
the gr Staters um this bill was put
forth uh after last year's bill that we
had with HB 572 that passed the house on
a two 10 to 177 Vote or something and
right now that Bill at 300% of poverty
sits in the Senate they tabled it so it
sit there um so what we'd like to do
with this bill
122 again it's about feeding kids uh I
taught for 40 years uh kids have to have
food uh to be able to uh learn
appropriately um I think we all have
copies of this bill
too yes um what we're hoping to do with
with this bill or the other bill is to
um amend it in some way at some point to
cause the art Ellison bill I don't know
if you're all familiar with art has been
a champion for kids feeding kids um he
right now is in hospice and our goal
would be if this were to pass that it
would be the art Ellison bill I mean
he's just passionate about it uh
there'll be an article in the paper I
think coming out on on his passion for
kids um as far as the financial part of
this um I think you've got the fiscal
note from the doe uh it's I think as
they do a fiscal note and you know more
about this than I do um that they try to
look at the highest potential of what
it's going to go I think we had 60 65%
uh uh participation in the school meals
which went up from what it originally
was during the pandemic when it with
universal meals um so they they put it
in there their financial note and I
probably can't answer to those questions
um Mr desay behind me probably knows
more about it than I do
um and I think they had said 50
million um oh I thought I had it here
but I guess I don't but um I I think
your fiscal notes in front of you
so um that's where we're at with it's
about feeding kids and we find that to
priority Micky is this on the on the
finan notice say reimbursement to
districts 50 million is that including
what we're currently doing or is this an
addition to what we're currently
doing this would be incremental to
current law so this would be a new
expense for the state above and beyond
okay question Dan just one question does
that fiscal note represent just the
actual cost of providing lunch or also
the cost on funding schools through the
uh you know education
formula this is just for the meal
reimbursement this uh
um different from when we've talked
about this before of uh School nutrition
eligibility changing adequacy that was
in the context of when we were talking
about
uh Medicaid direct CT would increase the
f&r populations and that Dynamic would
have impacted adequacy this bill here I
I don't believe will have any impact on
the Ed funding formula on ad quacy these
reimbursements yes if Mickey could you
clarify that a little because you know
the formula is based on the number of
kids eligible for free and clear and
unless we are having this bill just
change one and not affect the formula
you know I I just want to make sure I
understand exactly which is which my
understanding is the adequacy is based
on the federal definition of fnr whereas
this is expanding the state definition
of who were reimbursing for for expanded
meals so that's why it doesn't impact
level I'm
just I'm assuming they use the same
formula same I think it's 130 for free
and 185% for reduced of federal poverty
correct and and this would increase to
for
did you have a
comment go ahead only my comment is
since covid we've seen um an increase in
the number of hungry children this uh
bill would only refer to one meal a day
am I
correct up to two two meals a day okay
thank
you well what's the pleasure of the
committee oh okay thank you um you may
not know the answer to this but I'm
curious um the programs in place what is
the why they why do they need three new
positions to new staff positions I don't
know if you know that but someone
perhaps
might I wish I knew that answer it seems
like an awful lot of people for a
computer program that cost
$100,000 and then you need three people
to manage that and I think I said in my
committee that I I know a lot of
teachers that would like those jobs I
think for three people to manage it but
orbe it for me to to know how many but
you're right it's they've they're asking
for three people in addition to the
program
so I think you you share
my opinion too oh seems like a lot of
people yes can I just um I'd like to
motion and ought to pass motion um I I
would like today for us to be able to
and I I don't know if Art's listening
today or not um but it would sure be
nice if I could leave here today and and
go up to see him um the conquered
hospice and let him know that this at
least got through the first round of the
fiscal division 2 committee um that his
bill this is near and at his heart and
it's many families would benefit from
this it's different from the direct
Medicaid certification um increases the
percentage much like we've done with the
efas and and and that passed and I think
it would be good to have a comparable Mo
uh move toward that percentage so I
would like to move to I to pass this
amendment uh this
bill
second comment May um I still had
questions but obviously we can talk
during a motion too so I'm trying to
understand I remember when I was on the
school board in wiam that we were um
extremely frustrated with the u rules
and limitations imposed by the federal
launch program that you had to follow
guidelines which frankly resulted in a
humongous amount of food waste you were
not allowed to let kid not take the
Apple when they didn't want it you had
to give them the apple and you would see
them throw it in the trash 10 yards
later but if you didn't give them the
Apple then you'd violate the federal
guidelines and you wouldn't get
reimburse so I'm trying to understand I
saw note here right that you know
schools can either choose to participate
in the federal lunch program or not but
if not we are going to be on the hook
for the entire tab
so is you know what's what's going to
happen again when schools say hey the
state will pay us I don't have to take
those rules I can just get off the
federal lunch program give the kids
better food because frankly we wanted to
give them better food and now I'm not
losing any federal funds because the
state will Jump Right In wouldn't that
affect the FED fiscal note on this the
fiscal note probably assumes no change
in that I'm obviously I'm looking for
anybody's
opinion you have an answer well I have I
have a response I think um uh Mr chair
thank you I think that
the the question comes from a great
place but it's it's um centered perhaps
more in the substance of the policy
which has already been passed by the
floor so I think if we're talking about
fiscal impact we understand you know um
there is going to be some waste in every
program that's just a you know part of
what the unfortunate you know outcome of
many government programs is that
sometimes there's a little bit of you
know
government waste that's what it is um so
I I respectfully acknowledge your
concern about wasted apples but I don't
think that's probably it's probably a
diminus amount compared to the overall
program so I'm not sure that that is
really an important
discussion thank you I would like to
point out that I'm in no way questioning
policy my question is about the impact
on that policy and the effect it has on
the fiscal note because if the fiscal
note assumes that schools will continue
to stay in the S programs when we change
their incentives and remove a burden
limitation that caused them to stay on
the federal program when they were
unhappy with it like wiam was definitely
unhappy with that then the fiscal note
likely severely underrates the impact it
will have because if instead of just
have to paying the increment from 300 to
350 now for every school that comes out
of the federal and moves into the state
only program now I'm going to have to
pay the full tab so it was purely fiscal
note discussion I'd like to assure my
distinguished colleague because you know
here we hear from the Department I think
the department is here they could give
us some accuracy on that response okay
and Mr chair I think it might also be
helpful to hear the department talk
about their estimates for the
conservative lunch only um price instead
of you know maybe that difference if it
were a breakfast price
you good afternoon Melissa white
division director for learner support at
the Department of
Education Kelly Rambo Bureau
administrator for wellness and Nutrition
department of education to speak to the
uh question about the Staffing so so
this is to develop is to develop a brand
new system and Implement a new system in
which we do not currently have in place
so we'd have to do an income
verification process in order to verify
the students on this program met the
eligibility requirements we cannot use
any of the federal forms for this
program because that is not allowed by
the Fed so we'd have to develop our own
process these um positions that we're
looking at two would be in the um office
of wellness and ntion programs and then
one position in the data um division to
do the verification doing the um monthly
processing because the way that the food
and service program works is very
different than the other Federal
programs and that it's a monthly
reimbursement system so this isn't just
a oneandone or something that we're
doing once a year this is a payment
process that we would have to conduct on
a monthly basis and so that is why there
is the need for the Staffing positions
to be able to run that we cannot use the
positions that are federally funded to
operate the federal program to run this
program so the current staff that we
have now in the food and nutrition
programs is funded federally for the
most part and so that is why we're going
to have to have um generally funded
positions working on this because this
is a state program not a federal program
so hopefully that
clarifies the need for for those
positions and then with regards to would
that make a change to um perhaps
incentivizing um you know coming off of
the federal programs we cannot
anticipate that but if it laa decided to
no longer operate a federal uh school or
food program because the state is
covering it I mean the way that the
legislation is drafted the state would
be required to cover those cost costs
right thank you I appreciate the
clarification I just basically
understand then that the fiscal note
assumes as I expected that no change
will happen in the school behavior and
therefore if any schools do decide to go
at this point in time they are not
included any of those changes are not
included in the fiscal
note right just clarifying that I heard
correctly thank you so much that's
correct yes thanks I just wanted to ask
a followup about the previous statement
um for the three um additional um
positions uh I I just noticed that um if
you divide by three it's well over six
figures for a position does that include
salary and benefits or are we just
talking salary benefits and then all the
costs that are required to have a
position things like a a computer a
monthly doat charge everything that is
kind of the infrastructure in housing
that position great thank you and then
um could I just ask additional follow
um the um so my understanding if uh we
look at the USDA income eligibility
guidelines um so the state would be
required to pay the balance of the
reduced price um meals for students
qualifying right so we're looking at the
Delta between what the federal
government currently pays to what the
additional payment would be for you know
an additional meal or additional
qualification so the federal funding is
assumed that we would continue that and
then the state would make up the
addition that's correct it's the
difference between between the two of
them that's correct great thank you so
it's not only the 186 to 350% but it's
also the reduced price meal the
remaining balance on that reduced price
meal so you have a student that has a
reduced price meal because they're
between the 131 and the 185 we'd be
covering the difference of that as as
well and that's included in uh the
fiscal note thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question um it's my
understanding that there are a number of
other states that are doing this and
there are also a number of states that
have picked up a universal uh feeding
program for their children in their
state do you can you um give me any
information about those the community
eligible uh provision program so would
you be thank you for the question um
would you be speaking to the community
eligibility program or a universal meal
program meaning that the state would
just do just that cover the difference
it's it's my understanding that
Massachusetts and a couple of other
states have have picked that up as um an
offering that they provide to their
public schools and public charter
schools so that is correct um and each
state is uh unique and different how
they're administering that um I don't
have that information off the top of my
head but there are other states that are
um participating in a program such as
that and just a followup um I just
wanted to continue go too far a field
listic with this build okay okay with
with the community eligible provision
programs the way that those operate is
that if you're looking at a community
that has a significant number of free
and reduced qualified students let's say
80% and so you're not going to collect
you're going to use some other metric
for measuring poverty in that community
and so the local um coverage is the 20%
whereas the feds are covering that 80%
we don't have many communities that meet
that qualification and so even though
the federal government expanded that to
I think it was the 40 40 to 25% so that
so that 25 to 40% if you're having that
kind of measurement in your community so
let's say if they have that 25% the
local is still having to cover that 75%
so the F will cover the 25 the local
covers the 75 and then you have
everybody that's able to partake in that
program so we just make it very clear
that when we're talking about this this
works out well for communities that have
very large numbers of free and reduced
and large numbers of poverty percentages
that they're able to look to but when
you have a community that doesn't have
that we caution that because it does
fall upon that local um agency to cover
the cost and if they have the ability to
do that then it works well okay Mar yes
do we have an estimate of the number of
of families number of students this
would apply to that would get gathered
into this new program so this was the
part that we weren't able to give you an
exact number on we had to do an estimate
based on looking at the communities and
that percentage uh based on the um US
Census Bureau data that would meet that
18 5 to
350% and that's where we came up with
the projected 50 million based on that
have and so the the 50 um million that's
listed on the fiscal note is the minimum
um amount just to to clarify for that
too so um and these numbers are based
upon um the total enrollment of every
single student within the state um that
would have the cap ability to partake in
this program well the question was
there's 150,000 some students correct
how many are already free and reduced
and how many more are going to be added
so what we have is the actual that are
free and reduced and that's um about
40,000 currently right now um without
having the eligibility data um we we
can't um confidently answer that
question don't have the data to answer
that question
yes I just want to go back to your last
response about the 50 million being a
conservative estimate I'm looking at the
um the
calculation in the fiscal note which
said that it was based on providing
lunch uh for those 160,000 students and
if I look earlier in the in the note it
is mentioned that the lunch cost is
actually quite a bit more than a
breakfast cost so so it's entirely
plausible that a student may only get
one meal a day and it may in fact be
breakfast so I'm not sure that this is
possible I'm going to say based on the
fact this came out of the policy
committee is
itl uh I'm I'm not going to be able to
support the
OTP yes thank you Mr chair I'm not sure
whether this question is for the deal do
we Representatives or Micky
but um do we have a number on how much
money do we get Statewide from the
federal lunch
program Statewide all schools ballpark
number um thank you for the question so
in um let's just say the past um fiscal
year it was about $50 million with all
of the programs that we operate within
the department um and that could be
breakfast lunch um our fresh fruits and
million okay we have a motion Ma and
seconded for as o OTP could we just get
clarification on the comment about it
that it came out of a committee with the
itl it came to the house it came to the
didn't right to pass are to pass rep
and then you guys voted against theot
and then you voted it for the itl and
then you voted reconsideration and then
you reconsidered and then you voted to
pass I watched that I was four votes
it's very
exciting let's see okay my error it
didn't come from the policy committee
all right but it it did come as
OTP
okay I I still look at as we're setting
up another department
and
uh just in in my bones I'm I'm not in
favor of setting up a whole new
department so I'm I'm still not going to
be able to support the
OTP so you want to call their offer
any so we are calling the OTP call the
OTP motion for this yes
Representative
no representative briefing no
Representative no the clerk says no
representative wer
NOA
yes
yes I'm so sorry I didn't
[Laughter]
vote also um my my name is pronounced
hacken Phillips it's like a computer
um and I I vote
Yes seriously apologies for the
mispronunciation I come from Europe I
should know better my
bad so we were report back to full
Finance as itl on 22 I mean
1212 okay next on the
agenda is
Amendment oh wait I guess we do have to
do that don't we my apologies I assume
the other side
right oh because he's
not make motion
okay
and the motion is the motion is itl same
bill and calling the role representative
Griffin
yes
no
no okay motion passed is 54 okay so
1570 uh had originally a bunch of money
in it the money disappeared so there's
no money in it but and we wanted the
department of education to be able to go
to fiscal and request money for this uh
inventory of school
buildings however the language was not
in the bill to allow them to do that so
I'm introducing um
Amendment
H which allows the Department of
Education to go to fiscal to request
funds for this
inventory could I ask that a section be
added to this amendment please um can
I I'm sorry motion I need I need to get
a second I'll have a second okay now
you're on I I would like to ask that um
within this amendment we add a provision
that um the funds that are in building
non-aps
non-linguists they're non-aps to make
them non-aps that means that I I know I
know what it means but you just said
they are non-aps I believe that
yes
huh yeah and I would prefer with we get
so few dollars now for building Aid that
if they were non-aps and that at least
if there are funds left in the account
that they could carry forward to the
next bium right now they're disappearing
bium so that is correct School building
gate is non-lps until the end of the
bium any unexpended funds would go back
to the education trust fund and then be
budgeted Appropriations and the
following year so they go back to the
education trust fund correct and that's
non-aps you correct yeah so the funds
are
non-aps so
well yeah they lapse from the authority
of the school building Aid line into the
education trust fund at the end of the
banum and I'm not sure perhaps Amy would
know how much is lapsed each year I
can't imagine it's much but I don't
maybe Amy Clark from doe could share a
little bit of the history
please
uh for the record my name is Amy Clark
with the Department of Education in the
Bureau of school facilities um and yes
we have had funds laps um well we've
been in a moratorium for a really long
time so it's not like we've been through
many uh bium that We've Ended We've
Ended twice one I think if I recall it
was like
$700,000 that lapsed um so
um so not having that lapse would be
tacked on to the next uh fund which
helpful any other comment yes well most
of that education uh building fund is
going to pay off
bonds or at least a lot of it was so
that the bond payments continue so
there's always the money in there to pay
the bond payments and normally the
decisions for building Aid are made when
the budget comes out not sub quently
usually included in the budget isn't
that true um so there's a cap the law
currently caps building Aid at $50
million per year so I think what
representative Heath correct me if I'm
wrong what you're asking is that you
have that cap of 50 million plus
whatever um lapses at the end you be
have that non-aps so you'd still be able
to do this 50 million cap plus that
700,000 in that example so that in the
end you'd have an additional $700,000
for new projects in that particular
scenario exactly does anybody have any
objection to that addition
yes
okay Mr chair yes I if I could just
advocate for the opposite position for a
moment I mean I think we've already had
the discussion this year and I think
there is a bill on the table about
building Aid and the fact that there are
you know 450 buildings in our state that
are currently you know in various states
of disrepair which we're not exactly
sure as to the specific condition but we
do know that the
overwhelming fiscal responsibility of
the state to try to meet the current
need that we know about uh is not
currently being met with the 50 million
a year so I do think if it's the
intention every bium to allocate 50
million and that to building Aid
regardless of the tail which we all know
is dwindling um that the remainder of
whatever is left at the end of the bium
could stay and be allocated for the
following year since we all know that
that list of current applicants for
building Aid it gets longer every year
instead of getting shorter so I think
that that demonstrates there is an
ongoing
need yes Pur we also have a bill before
us to assess all the school buildings in
the state I think this is premature to
start talking about putting more money
into building a until we see what the
the needs are I think until we see that
assessment and I think you may have
something to do with it that we don't
know what what kind of thing I'm also in
Ed in how wellmaintained some of these
buildings are some people don't do any
maintenance and then say hey give me a
new building and that's another thing
we'd like to discover if you're not
taking care of what we gave you don't
come asking for new thank you well I
I I'm for moving things along quite
honestly I think that's a a very good
Amendment but not
now
okay
comment
yes I'd like to address the bill 1570
and this amendment which addresses the
need to know what represent wer just
spoke to is what's out in the field in
terms of construction new renovation
emergency projects what projects really
need uh support a building Aid so we can
put this 10-year plan into effect where
we know as a legislature what we have to
appropriate what are the needs out there
in the field now one thing I am
concerned about here is that we're
talking now about a vendor to a
contracted service of the department to
go out and with architect engineer to
assess what's in the field so we have a
good report coming back the same
criteria used wherever they go so we
don't get conflicting information
it's important that uh we realize that
it's going to be a contract and we may
have several contracts who knows and we
have about 33 million feet square feet
of buildings out there right now K
through 12 you multiply that times the
15 cents per square foot to do this
contracted that representative wer just
spoke to that comes out to roughly a
little shallow of $5 million $5 million
right there I would say that this money
this 5 million apart from what you're
doing with building Aid that should not
be
lapsing uh that money right there you
may have a contract you're coming to the
end of that two-year period which you
want to you may have funds encumbered
but we need to ensure that we have the
ability to do this properly and to carry
those monies forward to finish the job
so if you have a may have another
contractor you have to let and that's
right at the end of that two two million
two twoe period and you need to get that
contract going but may not have cumbered
anything yet it should be non-aps I'm
talking about the $5 million I'm not
talking about up to 50 million or
wherever you are per year so that's my
short presentation on that one right now
dealing with this bill right here this
portion should be
non-aps
so I would
assume this is a
question I assume when ad administrative
Services Cuts these contracts that are
multi-year and funded in the in the
initial year that that that encumbers
those funds for the rest of that
contract is that a reasonable assumption
well I I can respond I also chair the
commission which is for public school
infrastructure which we deal with access
and security and various safety
components and communicating with
emergency responders we've come to the
point where we've had
issues with money coming back we've had
then how do we reallocate that that
particular money they do not lapse and
we found that due to the fact that
during when we went through covid the
costs of doing business what we had
originally estimated came on sometimes
even double what we from the contractors
because we we couldn't find the
contractors but we needed to get the job
done for security and safety in the
schools I don't this that's just a
parallel where we have one program which
fun monies don't lapse this program is
one where we just need to know what's
out in the field I don't see any harm
and saying we're allocating $5 million
yes but the money won't lapse until we
finish doing the job and it could extend
beyond the the two-year
period so I'll do two amendments I I
don't know that's up to you guys to do
the Amendments as far as the lapsing
concern for the contract dollars that to
to implement the assessment this
amendment here would allow the
department to come to fiscal to get
money for the remainder of fiscal 25
your budget that leads us to the next
budget so next spring budget writers the
department should bring forward their 20
fiscal 26 and fiscal 27 costs associated
with this contract and budget writers
would consider it then so you wouldn't
have to worry about a lapsing provision
in this bill
today I trust you the check's in the
mail but um so it just actually the
check check isn't written yet yeah I
know the check's not written yet but
this is absolutely a program we we need
okay thank
you all right so we have a motion made
and seconded on Amendment
137h all those in favor of the amendment
to allow education to go to fiscal to
ask for money raise your
hands 9 Z so it's unanimous can I just
ask a clarifying question about the am
amendment that we just approved uh the
it looks like the
um ability to go to fiscal will be
available each year after the initial
assessment is that right or the initial
authorization uh the authorization in
paragraph one is for fiscal 25 only yeah
and then in fiscal 26 in year each year
thereafter it would be the expectation
that the department would put the amount
needed in their agency budget request
essentially and then it would be up to
just the normal budgeting process thank
you okay so now we have to have a a roll
call on 1570 as
amended and we need a motion first like
OTP SL a oh odpa thank
second okay um calling the all on otpa
1570 chairman amaric yes um
representative Griffin yes
representative Earth yes the clerk votes
yes uh chairman
Wier representative buo yes
representative Heath representative
muray yes and representative hacken Phil
yes okay so we'll report of 1570 as
amended to full Finance
asp
okay
[Music]
yeah
thank
you okay as we did discuss this last
Thursday and with the idea we're going
to come back and discuss it some more
here here we are the the amendment that
that I'm proposing is
105h does not change the under the the
approved
1583 that was approved by the house the
only thing it changes is the ad adequacy
statements so all of the other targeted
funds for the right hand side of the
formula
remain what this what F what the
amendment does is the amendment does
three things it raises the adequacy to
$735 and one cent as suggested by the
judge in the
conal uh
judgment so I'm assuming he had wisdom
to come up with that number so I adopted
that number as the top
number what this does is it increases
the amount of funds that need to be paid
out as part of
adequacy and so the second the funding
of the additional funds is basically
coming from the the Ed
education educ but the the additional
funds are coming from the
communities we we currently as a as a
state specify how much has to be devoted
to education all we're doing is we're
taking that number we're making a little
bit bigger so that in I'll pick on
Hampton in Hampton I've got on my tax
bill local education taxes and swep what
happens is the swept number is going to
go up and the local education number is
going to go down because the part two of
this bill says you can't increase your
appropriation so what that says is you
can't as the swep increases and your
your appropriation numbers here and you
have less money you can't recharge the
battery so to speak so it preempts that
unless you happen to be a swept
Community that's
budgeting as Hampton
is keeping
swept in that event Hampton will be able
to increase their local education
assessments based on the difference in
the swep they're not going to get
anymore so that is uh part one is the
adequacy part two of this bill is the
I'll call it a ceiling for the sake of
another word and part three of this is
the uh swept going back to the state
excess swept going back to the state
there will be more communities currently
approximately 29 million goes back to
the state will be coming back to the
state currently it's held in the local
communities what this says is is all
that sweat money including Hampton comes
back to the state under this amendment
the swep that return to the state is now
million however majority of communities
are not in it's they're not going to
know the difference because they're
never had the swep funds in their budget
to begin
with so yes thank you for that summary
um I just noticed that the number at the
top of this amendment differs from the
top of the amendment number that you
gave us last week so I was wondering if
you could tell us the difference between
the
two I can answer that the only
difference between Amendment 0913 from
last week and this one is the effective
date there was a effective date
you comments yes um there are a number
of things that go along with this
amendment um I certainly support
wholeheartedly the increase to
7,356
um this
amendment is a lot in terms
of thinking across our communities um I
really and truly think a a an amendment
of this magnitude needs a hearing a
public hearing um that said um swept it
raises um we're going from 363 million
um and the Rand we we know what the Rand
um hearing of the the Rand decision has
told us um but what does this really
look like in a local community and and
I'd like to hear Mickey to walk walk
through this amendment um the other
thing that concerns me greatly we've not
seen a penalty before and within this
amendment there is a penalty for not
submitting the funds in the excess web
towns um so I think that that's
something that we that we need to
understand a little bit better and I
think communities need to understand
that a little bit
better but the other thing that that
also concerns me is that while yes um
the we're moving the amount to
$735
And1 for that year but then it becomes
regressive and the amount starts to
decline
so I don't know if maybe Mickey maybe
I'm not understanding this right so if
Mickey you could walk through the
amendment and and talk about that and I
I would hope that um Mr chair that you
would consider a public hearing on this
amendment so that people could everybody
that this impacts which is our whole
state would somehow um have an
understanding so that everybody's aware
before we take action on
this okay part one of her
reest so I think the highlights of the
bill were were covered to this point
so you see the bill um amends section
one of the underlying bill which uh
House Bill 1583 as it passed the house
and came to this committee also had
changed base adequacy beginning in
fiscal 26 up to 4404 I believe this
would increase it to the 33561 the
conval number and then everything else
in this amendment starting on line 8 is
after House Bill 1583 it came to so the
relief funding and the fiscal capacity
disparity Aid is still intact under this
amendment yes but how what is the
regression of the amount the
7,000 as it goes as the years progress
so could you explain that part please so
the
73561 uh the base adequacy as well as
the other differentiated Aid components
by law would increase actually 2% per
year each year after this so when you
say
regress
or yeah the 73561 per pupil will
increase by 2% each year so it would be
going up it'd be going up it would not
be regressive at all correct correct
thank you yeah so the components of just
by the nature of the formula that we
have now U where you can kind of see
some Aid components go down they're in
the targeted AIDS which are based on
equalized valuations and as equalized
valuations increase in reality um by
amounts greater than you know we've seen
like 18% as high as some years um I
think the average for the last 40 years
is around 7% um statutorily those only
increase by 2% so you do see some
regression in that regard but that's way
into the weeds probably for what we're
talking about today um did you want me
to continue through the amendment or do
I feel like you've covered most things
but I can revisit or if you if I if I
gaps you recognize fill them in I I
think you I think you covered most
everything with with when you
highlighted I just wanted to reiterate
that the 1583 Provisions are unaffected
by this the question um here um and I
believe maybe I'm reading it wrong
uh it if in fact a school district
chooses to um increase the amount of
money that they choose to spend they
need a 2third vote of their legislature
yes they their governing body right so
um this is why I think we need a public
hearing so so that means in my mind in
Manchester it would be the board of
Mayor and all men could just do that
whenever they wanted to but it would be
town meeting day the community would now
basically so that's basically this is
just reiterating the fact that a town on
a yearly basis approves their budget and
that's what this means
yeah if they exceed the the limits that
are stated in this bill they would need
that two-thirds in that vote and just my
final question is about the penalty
we've I don't remember ever um a penalty
for a person that refuses to remit the
excess swept that a penalty would be um
either they their adequacy could be um
attached and any other state funds um
could be withheld
can you talk a little bit about
that uh I off the top of my head I'm not
aware of any other such uh Provisions in
law but I also I can't say for sure if
existed yeah I think I can address the
fallacy with that there'd be nothing to
locally but they are required Now by law
to put up to that's correct
but you said you said right and what you
said was if they refused to then the
state could attach their adequacy
there's no adequacy to attach because
they collect it locally you're still
them Mr
chair um so the way I read it on page
three um so this is section Roman
numeral one subsection C and
D basically the commissioner of Dr can
petition the state treasurer to withhold
the rooms and meals distribution if a
municipality is delinquent on their
excess payment to the state which would
be collected now double the
amount under the new calculation right
and then under D the commissioner of the
Dr could withhold any State education
Aid in
including the adequacy payments to
school districts of any
municipality if the Dr reports them
delinquent on submitting that excess
swept now um so as I read
it it's not just the adequacy But it
includes adequacy that could be withhold
withheld it could be any State education
AIDS so I I think that word any is a
little scary that we may need to have a
public hearing because now we're
suddenly putting forth not just adequacy
as a penalty and not just meals and
rooms
distribution but special ed building Aid
um you know we could go down the list of
you know those items in the education
trust fund that we all know exist so
this is a pretty big deal this um this
stick not carrot is a pretty big
stick yes if I may M thank you Mr chair
I would like to remind everyone that the
penalties here would be for or when a
town willing willfully disobeys state
law which um let's just assume that we
won't leave to see that happen because
this would not be fun at all two if a
town willfully disobeys state law which
I believe highly unlikely literally all
this bill says is that if they don't
want to pay me my whatever it is $1
million then we with withheld that
million dollars from the same place and
the town is literally unharmed because
they don't get a million on the left but
they kept the million on the right sorry
I'm pointing the wrong ways as I see
this as I say this but you know I mean
there is literally nothing in this law
that will take one cent from a town that
willfully disobeys Town state law why
are we even worried about it I would be
more more worried about a town who
chooses to disobey state law and frankly
if we are going to talk about the
penalties I would suggest penalties that
actually hurt not penalties that just
say oh you don't want to do this oh geez
I guess I'm going to take the money from
somewhere else and make sure you don't
lose a scent we are extremely lean in
this because it is a change I I'm fine
with the legislation as is right and
I'll support it but I I don't think the
concerns over the penalties are
something that would U warrant a lot of
consideration since the penalties are
essentially inexistent we just write
that
wrong does it State anywhere uh the
extent of the penalties because I don't
see any cap on the penalty here so
there's nothing to tell me that they
would withhold only what the excess is
and I also wonder why does it go to um
include meals in rooms uh to me that
just seems a little Draconian if we're
looking around for education programs I
Dr just just explain some of the
mechanics of what happens if a town is
not complying with state law so if a
town was required to pay the state money
and they did not pay the state the money
the state's option would be to sue them
so so that would be the normal course of
action and then the town would probably
want to pay that money because if they
lost the lawsuit the state could then
say you got to pay our attorney fees Etc
so that's the normal course of action
but litigation as you know can take time
so putting a um um we do this with doe2
reporting um we withhold state adequacy
from charter schools and district
schools if they do not complete their
financial reporting and so the way that
works is um they have to submit those
reports to us we ask them to do those
reports if they are not comping and they
don't submit those reports we say we're
going to hold on to your adequacy check
you are 100% entitled to it but we're
going to hold on to it until you finish
the report then we release it um I
imagine the same mechanics mechanics
would work here um where if a town did
not pay their excess swept to the state
the state would use uh whatever Aid the
state has or it's really up to the uh
discretion of the commissioner of Dr
discretion of Commissioner of Education
um to withhold that so they' be
incentivized to pay it before for
getting into that litigation aspect of
it so it's it's um it's a level of
gradation litigation is probably the
kind of Last Resort you want to go
down can I just have a quick followup
sure I think and that makes complete
sense Mark I um I just want to
acknowledge that when normal litigation
takes place um withholding additional
funds that are not particular to the
damages at you know at issue in the case
seems extra Draconian um to steal my
colleague's word because um you know you
wouldn't normally in a civil litigation
case that I'm aware of um withhold
additional funds that are not gerain to
the actual case of issue so you know the
meals and rooms issue is not an
educational issue and it's not an issue
before a CA before the this court system
if there was any litigation over you
know these payments or whatever so I
think you know that that is concerning I
think um furthermore I mean it's the
state's obligation and these District's
obligations to provide an education and
if any education Aid can be withheld it
may come a point where it's not feasible
to have you know education day-to-day
management operations of a district if
they don't have the money to do so just
because they're you know missing a small
balance so I am worried that this could
snowball um
and I um I think that clarification
would be needed by further Amendment if
we were going to go down this road I but
I for the record do not feel comfortable
going
there you just turned it off I apologize
it's not my day apparently um I just
want to quickly address uh the comments
from my colleague and just say that if
the town is concerned about the lack of
State funds preventing the ability to
educate kids all they got to do is
disburse the money they already
collected at that time this is not money
they possibly couldn't have collected
it's money they already collected in
property taxes and it's sitting in their
bank account I don't understand why the
uh 10 minutes it takes to per to run a
wire transfer to the state are something
that the town would want to avoid and
endanger the education of the kids I
submit to you that no town would do that
and therefore this is not a concern that
we should spend a lot of di
on yes Mary thank you Mr chair
so I love 1583 I think it's great as is
um I there are components of the
amendment that I
like I just I would like to act on
1583 just to pass it out of division 2
send it over to full finance and then
have a public public hearing on the
amendment and then after that if we
could have the um maybe we could have a
public hearing on Tuesday morning we
could do an amendment to the um calendar
and have a public hearing on Tuesday
morning when we're all going to be here
anyway um before we take a final action
on the amendment just I really and truly
think this is this is a big deal it's
just not some little amendment that that
we know about it but everybody doesn't
else doesn't know about it and I think
there are things
that in my experience here it's the
normal practice that we have a hearing
on an amendment that changes the impact
of of a piece of
legislation to a a fairly significant
point and and I I really and truly think
I'm not imagining it um oh ask the
chairman Mr chairman
it is probably appropriate okay thank
you Mr chairman then I would I would say
we'll do
it are you going to be able to finish
think no
no so at 9
o'
Amendment
today
well I I don't think 9 o' on Tuesday is
the right time okay because that gives
us one hour and okay if you're going to
hold a public hearing and and you're
expecting a crowd I don't think that's
the yeah division one is going to meet
at one on
Wednesday of course Thursday we'll have
a
session well we can have it in the
morning on Wednesday okay Wes morning at
10 well today's
Friday wouldn't get in the calendar well
we could do it at a you know they amend
it post it with a Amendment a or
whatever they call it you can do it no I
could request yes Mr chair I think there
was an amendment rule that allows an
amendment to the calendar if with
three-day notice for a public hearing so
if we got it in today before 5 Monday
Tuesday Wednesday that's three day
notice depends on the clerk and
sometimes he's obstinate about No it
should have been here Wednesday before
noon and then we can take a vote on 1583
as is so then we it's ready to go to
division of the full Finance it's good
it'll have to carry the amendment or not
okay
okay I mean it's possible I know that
Ways and Means still has several sweat
bills before them as well so it could
potentially be Germain to those bills as
well I think the swap bills are going
going to interim
study they are going to interim
study but we don't want to attack our I
that
well let's ask the
clerk should we take a quick recess to
ask the clerk yeah let's take it let's
take break until quarter after thank you
Mr chair and thank you Mr chairman
support
e
okay to answer the question we will
schedule a public
hearing properly noticed we're not going
to try to do it next
week no
because we do because this is a second
committee bill so it's not do back until
April 4th so looking at a calendar was
The Prudent thing to do to say let's do
it right so we will find a time to have
a public hearing and then we'll have
another work
session having said that has anybody
else got any thing they want
now yeah I have one more concern Mr
chair yes uh so on page
two subsection
section I'm a little bit worried
about the way that I read it maybe I'm
incorrect is that once the appropriation
determination for swept is
determined it's it's basically locked in
and
that there isn't an ability to kind of
in build out from that so so that I'm a
little concerned that some communities
who are currently really struggling with
their you know property tax issues
and school financing issues would really
be kind of Frozen in time and ability to
address that under the
financing and that you know down this
threeyear average percent change would
really prevent them for making
meaningful changes in the future that
that does concern me quite a bit no they
can the two-third vote right so again I
think that you know asking any Community
that's really struggling to reach
66% at a town budget meeting to approve
a major you know Bond or a major you
know change for their you know a real
fundamental change for the way that they
finance our schools you know if they so
choose it would be nearly impossible to
reach that consensus and currently under
law it's just a simple majority so my
question is
why would we want to increase a hurdle
raise the height for these communities
if they are ready to make those changes
with a simple majority under current law
now why would we want to make it higher
and harder for them to make those
changes
comment so I'd like to point out these
are the wealthiest communities in the
state that already have the highest per
pupil spending in the state by huge
margins so that is the reason to have
there if that's true I'd like to hear
from those communities and as well as
you know why would we hand cap or tie
their hands from being able to make
additional changes if if that's the case
I I would be interested in hearing you
know from them at this at this hearing
I'm not sure that this is an appropriate
limitation
like effective limitation through the
here yes can I just add quickly I think
there's a assuming homogeneity of any
particular Community um isn't realistic
uh when I think of some communities um
exitor comes to mind which appears to be
a wealthy community has a significant
amount of poverty in exitor and they
struggle with a lot of these things half
of their students are on free and
reduced lunch so I think assuming
homogeneity of communities um that
either you're a wealthy community or not
um is
misleading I wasn't making any
assumptions these are the
towns and it'll be true in the even more
so in this case that
have
the
largest surpluses if you will that
collect more money by
they it's the the EXs we Town exactly so
is that's not an assumption that's a
fact and it's going to get bigger in
fact more towns will be involved our our
town for instance is a very Middle Town
sometimes would' probably be a over and
sometimes we'd probably be under but
under this we be
over there were 49 towns that had excess
swept before we've added four
more like this I thought we'd had more
it's only four more it's 53 Towns now
some of them
not yes Mr chair I just respectfully
reserve the right to make Amendment
changes after the public hearing just
well that's why we're having a public
hearing thank you thank you I I I was I
was fishing to say is there something
glaring that we need to fix now for the
public
hearing so let's defer to the public
hearing all
well that's this is the one where we
have the tier the levels of special ed
why didn't we why didn't we address this
because you gave us that Amendment Mr
chair I think we got overloaded s us
over the Ed but also I thought there was
a disagreement with whether or not the
two-year lag numbers the doe could be
replaced with like more timely numbers
and I think there was going to be some
coming back and forth discussing about
on
than
so I'll have Brian walk walk through the
memo um kind of um this is a new data
set we'd be introducing into adequacy so
it just took a little bit of time for us
to talk with the sped Bureau and figure
out how it would would roll into
adequacy and if there would be any
glitches along the way and so Brian's
going to walk through kind of how
adequacy sped currently matches and then
how this would change that a little bit
and then there was a recommendation uh
before the committee or two couple
options before the committee as far as
how you want to deal with how the sped
data rolls into the adequacy
formula hi good afternoon as Mark
mentioned my name is Brian e and I work
for the Bureau of school Finance with
Department of Education so I can just
quickly walk through how like Mark
mentioned how sped is currently match
for adequacy so how we determine if a
student is eligible for special
education differential different
differentiated Aid is essentially
determining if a student is eligible for
adequacy and then matching them to say
is this student also receiving special
education services if so that student is
eligible for that additional sped Aid so
that's how we currently do it so this
first section on the hand oute uh bullet
two that states that using that method
which is current law we identified
3,965 sped students for fy2 24 being
school year
23 so this bill how as it's proposed is
that it would instead of um oh and also
what's important is that we look at if a
student's eligible receiving special
education services any time of that year
so it's not like any point in time it's
any time during that school year if they
receive those services so um how would
change that data matching is that it
wouldn't be looking at just any time of
the year it'd be looking at those
October 1st collection dates which is
how they determine what environment
those students are in which is those
categories a b and c which are on the
bill so therefore any students uh
identified as receiving special
education services or even entering into
a public District in New Hampshire after
101 would not be included in those uh
what we call headcounts as of October
1st so doing that analysis bullet two we
identified
26334 sped students in
fy4 which is 4,631 students identified
as receiving sped Services after or
entering a New Hampshire District uh
public school after 101 so that's the
discrepancy that we identified that is a
technical uh deficiency with the
bill so if we were to implement the bill
as it's written we would be not
including those 4,631 students as they
aren't identified on those uh October
1st headcount um
collection and and so as Mark mentioned
we have some ideas or a idea we want to
propose uh in order to pay ensure that
all students receiving special educ
education services are receiving special
education Aid and that would be the
language to address this limitation and
that would be any pupil receiving
special education services identified by
the department and was not identified in
those October 1st headcount date um
headcounts uh to determine those
disability categories a b or c those
students shall receive Aid under
category a so that would take all those
students that were mismatched or
unmatched essentially uh that were
receiving special education services
throughout the year just not on the
October 1st uh collection essentially
those students would be receiving aid
under category a or an aid amount
specified by the legislature uh that
could be um updated as well so we did
the analysis of looking you know if we
were to include all those special
education um students as of 101 so as
received that would be 11 million a year
and if we were to add that additional C
well add um all those unmatch students
as category a that would be the second
bullet there which would be 17.7 million
each year if we were to ensure that
every student would be receiving special
education differentiated Aid under this
bill my question is is this is this an
anomaly this October one date or is that
used for a lot of things it would be
yeah it's our beginning of year year so
just like any other student uh Records
that are submitted to the department
it's as of 101 so it kind of follows
that same principle um student um status
okay so it's it's we do October one is
kind of our beginning of the year count
so we use it for forecasting in the
future we use that October 1 date is
very common but what we do with a lot of
other programs like the f&r program is
we we say how many f&r students you have
October 1 but we're going to check back
in with you at the end of the year and
so we haven't talked with it another way
to do this um instead of changing the
law um would be to ask the sped team to
do a second data collection I don't know
if they can do that cuz this really well
I I can't speak to them as far as if
they can do a second data collection but
they could ask them at the end of the
year tell us where you're at um I don't
think they do full year reporting at the
speed I think they really do snapshot
count um so um yeah to to align them
with the other data collection processes
the bed Bureau would have to double
their data collection um so I don't know
if they're pred to do that or if they
have the resources to do that um so yeah
that's just it's a little bit it's a
little bit different than our data
collection methods we have for some of
the other differential Aid components so
this says that somebody's going to
receive at least a level a yes
okay yes Mary thank you Mr chair
so Federal Law requires a reporting of
information about the extent to which
students receive services so I think
what I'm hearing you say is you
can't do this with the three categories
currently I I don't um I believe it's
the federal requirement it's federal
reporting requirements that does the
October one snapshot of what the
disability categories are right as of
that date um so any additional data
collection would be uh State dat State
data collection which would be different
so so on your I don't know what you call
it now the i4c system that you'd have
you can put in more categories so can't
you just work with the school dist the
superintendent and say that they need to
come up with the methodology I mean it's
very clear what we're asking for that
that they would instead of reporting one
they'd be be reporting three categories
of special ed students and the money
would be driven by
that so yeah we have we have data
collection um uh we have a data
collection tool we have I4
we're going to be transition to
Alma um we wouldn't be able to do that
right away building a whole new data
collection system because that's there's
the there's the data collection team
which is Kaitlin's team and then there's
the sped bureau's team which does
different data collection that feeds
into the data warehouse so um what
you're asking I don't think um Caitlyn's
data team our our data team could do
that right away but we certainly could
do that I just don't know um off the top
of my head I can't tell you if that
requires contract modifications or
anything else so you s oops so you're
saying you can do it but it's just going
to take you time so can we pass this
bill as is or do you want it amended
yeah so the the reason for the amendment
is if you pass as is it's only going to
cost you $11 million extra but you'll be
you'll be Pro you'll be not getting what
we wanted well I I spoke with
representative Vlad the technical fix
here adding this little L any people
receiving special ed services will be
category a aligns close to what it was
intended for it to be um if you don't do
the sort of technical Amendment um there
could be students receiving sped
services that don't receive sped
differential Aid and therefore someone
could Challenge and say that's
unconstitutional because the state
definition of adequacy says you shall
get sped Aid if you are receiving sped
Services um so that's kind of you have a
little bit of constitutional risk there
if you don't add the technical Amendment
um but then again the technical
Amendment costs you an extra 17.7
million the other way to get there would
be to do what you're describing is do a
second data collection that might cost
more than 17 million because then you'd
pick up more category B's and category
C's instead of defaulting to a um just a
different approach but if I may just ask
one final question um wouldn't the
information then be more
accurate uh yeah you would have more
detailed information thank
you thank you Mr chair so I'm just
trying to understand you I think you
said that it was not the intent of the
bill at all to exclude any children
from receiving this you know
differential Aid it just happened that
the way the language is defined it
requires them to be categorized and you
the combined efforts of the school
districts and the doe will result in
some kids 46 31 you know 4631 not being
categorized in time and therefore not
eligible for the funding is that my
understanding my is my understanding
correct yeah so I can't speak I can't
speak to representative lad's intent but
I just I just I just I just walk this by
him through in the hallway and he said
this is what he wanted um so or he said
this is good I just want to state that
if that is the intent you know of the
bill and the wording is just a mistake
that produces a you know unre you know
an undesired result I have no problem
you know amending the bill to reflect
the correct policy meeting again right
but you know all I'm saying is again
there is no intent to change policy in
this case I think the policy is sound
right so if it's just a matter of fixing
language that does not match the what
the house thought they were voting on
right yes thank you Mr chair so the
these students uh would who are not
initially identified default to category
a I'm assuming if they're actually
category C at some point in the year
they get mov to the appropr the next
payment the next year's payment they'll
get coded in so they would stay a for an
entire year and then the next year they
would move to yeah from October 2nd to
the end of the school year they' be in
that a bucket and then next year when
the data collection as long as they
stayed in their District public school
be so Mickey you you're absorbing all
this so oh uh I was going to say we can
have an amendment drafted it sounds like
we're going to have another work session
on house bu 1583 perhaps we also meet on
this one too with an amendments for me
and it'll give us and the department to
just present something maybe update the
fiscal note to to a line or give you a
number true to the referenced amendment
that we draft as well for you to
consider okay
yeah two questions first of all just
clarification is the the new cost 17.7
million or 17.7 million the increase
cost over above the 11 million oh no it'
be new cost so it be 11 million so as so
the increase is 6.7
million well so the increase to ensure
that all students would be a toal to Al
increase above what's current law is
17.7 million if we were to implement the
law as written it would be increase 11
million over current law yeah the
technical Amendment cost 6.6 yeah okay
okay thank you so here's my question if
I'm not if I'm understanding correctly
the base Bill let's call
it applies to roughly 31,000 St students
uh the base Bill actually since it was
narrowly defined to the data collection
methodologies of our sped Bureau it only
impacted 26,000 students not the full
Universal sped students okay okay fair
good thank you 26,000 students okay and
the potential
modification is 4600 students uh correct
add to them too though yep okay so
that's about one the number of students
of the of the 26,000 roughly right uh
about a 20% increase yep so we got about
20% increase in students all of whom are
going into the least expensive bucket
but we get a 50 more than 50% increase
in the
cost so I can actually well I have it
kind of broken out by uh table here with
all the calculations
so the Mark's doing on the fly as well
um so if we were to have category a
which
be
so it's kind of hard to describe
essentially but I can kind of show or we
can kind of exp explain yeah it's hard
yeah I think I mean that's a good
question we should look at the numbers
closely but um whether it's picking up a
lot of category B's or category C's um
so we could we could try to deal we
could bring something that dives deeper
into those numbers yeah confirm that
yeah yeah so kind of just to briefly go
over the 11 million that covers all the
students identified by the 101
collection um the majority of it would
be category a those are that's the bulk
of it so when you apply the additional
uh you know 4,000 students to the
category a it increases it by 12 uh the
total total sped Aid by 12 million so
it's proportionally it might just might
have to explain a little better I think
how it proportionately works out yeah I
think representative like just running
the numbers it's basically on average um
those 4600 students on average are
costing additional
1,425 I'm just doing some quick math I
think it's
$1,425 so it appears those those more
transient population students happen to
be the higher category students because
they are above if they were all a then
it would be zero so it is moving it is
moving the number so it could be in the
data if we looked at the data it could
be those transient students are category
B and C that's kind of what you're
pointing out it seems to be a little bit
outside of what Norm would expect you'd
expect closer to zero um but yeah we can
look into to see those students and see
if they are coded d and c um like you're
kind of pointing out with your
math yeah just to clarify cuz honestly
by this point in time I you know I think
I understand but I just want to double
check I'll
wait hang on I'm happy to wait for
Mickey no no by all means seriously I I
I mean it I'm happy to wait I um so
could you remind me which of the
categories is the you know larger
Financial impact and which is less so
it's the it's when you don't have
regular class when you spend uh the
least like in residential placement
spending not a lot of time in a regular
classroom so which of them is that a b
or c c so basically a would be your you
know lesser expense and then we go to
intermediate and then to high costs
right my understanding and again that's
what I would appreciate if you'd correct
if I misrepresent is that when we
originally had this bill this 11 million
in Impact
reflected an increase for certain
students and a decrease for others so
the net impact no no every everyone the
way represent Vlad designed it is
everyone's getting the same amount it's
just now we're paying extra for category
B and category C okay so there was no no
student for which a school would have
received less sped funds we just gave
them additional funds I think you just
figured out the math I think you now
you've you've knocked it out uh under
the under the amended language we are
dropping 4,000 students so that's cost
there that's why that 1,000 number
showing up is because under the bill
with the technical error coming through
we're actually spending less money on
sped um but with the technical Amendment
we're bringing back up to kind of
current law and adding um additional So
yeah thank you I think you've helped I
appreciate it when when a clarification
question clarifies it's always a nice
outcome thank you questions are good
things I don't know what he just
[Laughter]
said
B basically we have yeah we have um yeah
don't have to go into it it's all it's
all technical if you're saying yes
yes we had
kids and we based this amount in
category a
as
being6 added on the base cost or of the
base cost excuse me of the base cost so
it came down what 2,000 some OD dollars
it was a little bit higher than what
we're paying right now for special Alit
the second category
B was 1.2 times the base
cost and then category C which is all
those residential placement kids
homeschoolers and those which are home
homeschool Homebound and might be in the
hospitals that was 1.8 times that base
the base that was used was the base that
we uh costed out as the the cost of the
a the low average
$444 not on base the base cost now so
doing that calculation for all the
students in these various categories we
came up that maybe we have bad math in
policy of $35 million total on top of
the
66 or 34 million somewhere around that
neighborhood I don't have any of that
paperwork in front of me now yeah and so
I'm not figuring how it's being
calculated because just increasing by $
11 million it's it's
it's as you intended it represent lad it
should have been closed 17 and I don't
know what factors you Ed in your ma
whether you included swep whether you
included the whole harmless so I don't
know if you back some of it's going to
eat away at the whole Harless we we
simply took the base cost the a
projected base cost of
4,44 and then and then multiplied for
that first a category times the 6 that's
what we used to
$2,642 per kit then the next category B
we took the 1.2 multiplied that times
the 44 and it came down $5,280
and and then the next category C 1.8
times would be
$7,923 multiplying those categories by
the number of kids in those categories I
understand the October one deadline is
is giving a concern I get that but in
category a there's 24,1 153 kids
multiply that times
2,642 you get a numbers the same thing
for the B and adding those up it it came
$35,000 $ 35,1
122643 6
$643 I I'm just not following along with
what's being said here yeah represent
your calculation doesn't include eating
swep though but this one's not this is
you pure left of
right the the way this bill was written
it was it was written so that we would
start this whole thing with this
weighted formula based upon that 4404
figure not what's going on in any other
component that's where we wanted to
start
recognizing that this may in the upper
end eliminate a little bit of what we
have to cost out in CAD a and and and
and and because we're multiplying times
a different number three and a half
times the 10 times yeah I may if I may
have a question and the comment um if I
may start with a question could you just
confirm what we were talking about
earlier that there was never an intent
for this bill to you know Miss the 46 31
kids and the original intent was to make
sure that every kid got at least
category a
funding as I mentioned when I testified
initially here in the committee was that
there's several ways in which we're
getting these numbers if you were
talking to director foret the number
would be closer to 28,000 kids because
she does a one-time shot look at and the
guys that are budget guys behind me do
it differently and so they come up with
the 31,000 kids and so so we're going
along with the budget guys okay so then
it would be a yes-ish to my question per
me would the answer be a yes no I I I I
think I hear a yes but I just want to
make sure that the intent was to include
this 4631 that we are looking to include
with this amendment yeah just checking
and the other thing that I will say and
that was the comment part is
that as we all know in this room the
frequent people in this room the
education formula is a complicated beast
and every time you touch it in one place
something happens in another and I would
suggest that at this time trying to do a
full impact on what happen happens on
the right side is probably more than we
can handle for the next year there is a
budget process next year and I'm sure
we'll play a lot with it so I I would
suggest that for now I just want to get
you know this done in time and you know
keep it reasonably simple and you know
come back to it in one year and I'm sure
we'll have at it you know that that's
just so much when you start looking at
everything and I think the policy
already you know pretty much said that
what happens on on the right side is
approved by the house whether they
thought about it or not representative
the the I I understand what you're
saying there's there's two things which
we have to look at and remember that we
are trying to support and differentiated
Aid right now all IEPs equally we know
that is not the way it works for those
13 IEPs we have some students that are
traumatic brain injured that are mute
which are blind which are orthopedically
handicapped go down that list others
maybe get in just you know two hour an
hour two different times a week on
speech and oftentimes that may be a Dev
developmentally delay which is you know
questionable in itself so but the other
component of this is that we need to get
weighted into our formula uh and
recognize that that's an important
component figures can change yes but
this concept needs to be placed in there
and we need to look at that secondly
that the largest complaint we get from
school districts is that when one of
these students moves into their District
the real costly student when they have a
a great education program in the school
and with all the services it becomes a
magnet
school and that by that you have folks
around saying I want my kid going there
to get that special education service so
there there there it be that these are
the questions that now I was called into
the speaker's office summer before last
he had a board member sitting right
there with them say how are we going to
address this $1.5 million figure we have
for special what which we don't have the
money for and we had some of these kids
move into town on us so special EDS a
serious issue it's got to addressed and
whether you fund it the way we had you
know put forward which is important we
need to get weighted amounts in this we
have tried now several years running to
do this and there are very few states
that don't do this right now they they
do the weighted I think we're all on
board
okay I don't think that's a
problem the numbers I know it's it's
numbers with you guys could I just ask a
question about the cat a pie in the
category C sure so Rick you and I have
had a conversation a million times about
the those kiddos who are the most severe
and Cat Aid has a well it's not cat Aid
any special at Aid has a Year's drag on
it so if I'm a school district and I
have a child who moves in and it's
expense is going to be $300,000 I don't
get repaid till the following year um is
it your hope that this category C will
to some extent remediate that it's going
to it's going to address it to a degree
but
for you know how that formula works you
guys have talked about this many times
the first three and a half times the
average cost $20,000 per kid that's
$70,000 that district has to put up
first you might subtract out of that
$2,100 or $2,300 for a differentiated
Aid so the bulk of that 70 grand they to
cough up from three and a half times to
10 times that you have the the state
will put up 80% they have to come up
with the other
20% yes and and then then you have that
total amount 10 over 10 times but
oftentimes we have more kids showing up
in this
category and so it's pro rated down and
we have pro rated it down some years
almost close to
70% uh of what they should be receiving
now we in last several years we've tried
to do it at 100% we have couple we're
slipping back down around
89% so it it's it's a dreadful situation
we got to help all this is not a donor
versus non-donor right th this is a
issue for
everybody yeah yeah
so I thought I heard we needed to do an
amendment yeah I was just going to ask
Mr chair do you think we could draw an
amendment that would add the language
that the department just talked about to
try to catch those 4,000 some odd kids
that were not accounted for on October
1st
amendment we we can draft that and I
think one other thing to clarify too is
when was this intended to be effective
so subparagraph 1 D1 seems to apply in
fiscal 20 uh five and sub paragraph 3
talks about in two in July 21st or
excuse me July 1st 2025 in year
thereafter so I just want to clarify
when would be year one of this
change that's ay
question well policy already put it to
you we wanted the first year well the
school budget is going to be being
voted just got
voted and
so if we make this effective
anytime before March of next
year then it'll be effective March of
next year
locally so what what date the July
one if if the change was to be July 1
the year beginning July 1 2025 now
you're into the next banial cycle for
the budget to uh so it would it would
align um because this talks about uh you
know I I don't know represent lad if
your intention was it to be during this
the the budget that's already enacted or
for the next budget that's kind of where
there's a conflict between these two
paragraphs so e either way we can draft
in an amendment uh what was your
intention get it done as soon as
possible okay I'll go with that
everybody comfortable with that yeah I
Y
money so what what
date 60 days
after signing or what I don't have I
think we would make it eff of July 1
2024 okay yeah so we can yes I I'll work
with the Department to not only
incorporate their corrective language
here but also just make sure the timing
works with the intent of of what
representative lad is looking to do and
we can have an amendment for the next
work session okay try to get it to
everyone ahead of time to review all
right thank you we thank you for your
support m yes can I just add one one
thing so I I support what representative
lad's talking about but also remember we
were all on the special committee to
study uh for school funding and it was
really that committee's intent intent um
for um for these Provisions particularly
the two Provisions in 1583 and the one
provision in um one we're talking about
16 to um to take effect um um 7124 four
another provision in 1583 adjusting the
base from 4100 to 4400 would take effect
7125 but the committee's intention was
also to uh to make to look at I I think
without the committee did
not have the luxury at looking at policy
language we were looking at um cost um
um cost ball parks at that point and
remember we were doing some negotiating
and give take on that and what we had
decided was 1656 would create three
categories an increase of 35 million
over current law effective 71 2024 so 35
million is what represented Vlad was
talking about very different than what
were you know the the finances that we
saw today and then I believe 1583 as
voted by the house um talked about
fiscal capacity it Grant 39 million over
current law the um what did we call it
the enhanced free and reduced lunch
Grant 25 million over current law both
effective 7124 and then the increase of
the base from 4182 to 444 for a cost
increase of $35 million effective
71225 and my understanding is that's
what the the special subcommittee uh
approved and I'm hoping that
1656 it's going to be the amendment to
1656 is going to be drafted so that it
follows that $35 million increase as
intended by the subcommittee over
current law whether that means that
we're not going to eat into hold
harmless but but as representative lad
said this is something that impacts
every District across the state because
every district has um struggling with
special education we all agree with you
yeah so I just want to make sure that
we're we're heing to the intent of yes
of that special thank thank you very
much for listening okay I guess we're
done for today we'll have this party
again
sometime